moi je suis la police et je suis sexy 1
et j'ai un fusil ou encore peu connu du
grand public
richardson s'est fait rouler sa bosse
depuis dix ans il multiplie les soirées
de comédie le caméo à la télé et au
cinéma
mais c'est grâce à ses vidéos sur
youtube qu'il a rejoint un public plus
large et gagne en notoriété
ridge à ce jeu les consoeurs retrouve
ici à la roquette sur le plateau mont
royal à montréal parce que croient
plusieurs années tu étais porte ici est
ce qu'on disait c'est que tu étais le
seul norman qui s'était jamais battu
c'est vrai c'est possible ça moi je suis
plutôt gens de deux feuilles et ici il
faut se parler mais jamais défaut d'être
un bagarreur dans la vie l'humoriste de
41 en lutte depuis plusieurs années pour
faire sa place dans le milieu compte est
gentil de l'humour et vendre une soit sa
me soit quand les gens se rencontrent en
général pour s'amuser mais moi je suis
en train de faire des blagues sur des
scènes je suis dans un festival excès
obscures depuis trois ans il se consacre
exclusivement l'humour tu répètes c'est
le pili mines les derniers comme les
gens disaient puis et élimine les
derniers touristes duction par rapporte
que ton texte soit et à la virgule près
mardi il y participer ou ethnique show
un micro ouvert hebdomadaire animé par
l'humoriste et youtube arc reach qui
donne la parole à des artistes de la
relève de la diversité banjo plus de
mauvaises jour dans ton cerveau ça via
les intérêts de la même place puisque
vraiment juste à savoir une bonne chose
car qu'elle va sortir quand tu vas là
dit il devant les gentils comme le
gymnase de deluz mourir sur le fallait
comedy club c'est ma présence sur scène
j'ai oublié que les projets sont pas en
danger
pour ceux qui me connaissent pas je me
présente je m'appelle richardson zéphir
loin des rires gras de l'humour grivois
et de la vulgarité richardson zéphir
mise sur l'humour d'observation et sur
la bienveillance que faire rire tant
mieux donc temps pour de vrai que ça
m'arrache le monde viennent pourrir
mais je veux apporter des enjeux
d'actualité pour lieu de jeu sur les
comptes de monde c'est de donner
proposer des solutions
un parfois comiques parfois réels et
cela dans l'escrimé s'est exprimé hier
claire au passé obscur
c'est dire si elles étaient fermées en
prison richardson zéphir est un des
nombreux nouveaux visages à découvrir
dans le cadre du zoofest qui débute ce
soir
sina bien alexandre charti radio canada
montréal